and there was a jarring comment from
congresswoman veronica escobar upon
greeting kamala harris
at the el paso airport today welcome to
el paso welcome to my community
to the new ellis island to the capital
of the border
i have a heart full of gratitude because
we finally have an administration
willing to tackle the big challenges
willing to tackle
challenges in a meaningful thoughtful
strategic
compassionate way and understanding
what's driving people from their home
what's making them arrive at our
nation's front door
joining me now victor davis hanson
hoover institution senior fellow
victor the ellis island
of 2021. tee off on that for a moment
yeah every element of that comparison is
pathetic
laura ellis island everybody came
legally
from 1890 and uh to 1924 it was legal
legal
and they came with they were audited
they were authenticated there were
people who gave them health checks
people coming across the rio grande
especially at
el paso in the state of texas they're
coming for the most part illegally
we we don't have any idea in the middle
of a pandemic whether they've been
vaccinated
probably not or whether they're active
carriers 5 000 border and customs patrol
officers have been infected they were
diverse at
ellis island they came from all over the
world this is just one group of
spanish-speaking
uh peoples it's not diverse like ellis
island
and they came with the expected
expectation
laura to assimilate rapidly to integrate
to intermarry
that's not the message we're giving
these uh immigrants that are coming
illegally we're telling them that
they're part of a tribal
identity it's what's happening in
america and they came you know that
people forget about ellis island it was
measured
i know that some years days they might
have five or six thousand but
over that 36 year period there was about
12
12 million people who arrived here we're
getting up to two million so we're
getting six to seven
times more per year across the southern
border than we did through ellis island
every element of that comparison is just
factually wrong
and it's kind of insulting to the people
who follow the rules
or grandparents or great-grandparents or
parents that did that
it's really sickening yeah my
grandparents on my mom's side came
through ellis island and
i remember hearing hearing some of those
distant uh stories
i i i took my breath away that
comparison
now i want to play something else that
harris said today at the border
i strongly believe that most people
don't want to leave home
and when they do it is because either
they are fleeing some harm
or because to stay means that they
cannot provide for the basic necessities
of their family
victor well first of all that doesn't
qualify them for asylee status in the
united states she doesn't even know the
law and she's supposedly this great
lawyer
that's not that's not persecution that's
under under under one of the causes
uh listed under the uh asylum statute
yeah and that's also a lie we have pew
polls lawyer that are taken
frequently and usually mexico alone
people pull about 50 percent of the
mexican population says
if given the opportunity or chance they
would move to the united states
immediately
half the country 55 million 60 million
people would come
if you open the borders all of uh
central america and mexico would come
because for all the criticisms of
america we're a constitutional state
with individual liberty and we kind of
allow people to be prosperous
secure and happy in a way that's
impossible in their homeland
so they would all come and yet that's
the big disconnect isn't it the left
says this is a terrible country
and then they can't explain why
everybody wants to come to a racist
country
and it never and it's because they don't
even believe their own rhetoric they're
so cynical
victor thank you great to see you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else